we're gonna do something today called
big dick history
the quiz are you ready yep okay
just buzz in by yelling your name if you
know the answer okay
number one what historical figures
swang and wang was described by a time
magazine journalist in 1927
as a quote maltreated strip of buckskin
shoelace wait a minute can i hear the
question again
what historical figures swang and wang
was described by a time
magazine journalist in 1927 as a
malt-treated strip of buckskin
shoelace is it rasputin
napoleon prince albert or vladimir lenin
oh uh it would be i'm going to say sona
yes sona lenin incorrect i'm going to
say napoleon napoleon is correct
god damn it all right one point uh they
actually
claimed to have napoleon's penis so
that's right
the others would not be available for
inspection whereas i think napoleon's
would be my understanding is it's
actually like a book sellers
keep in mind a lot of this research is
rumor-based but for our purposes
who cares uh you know it's not only
owned
napoleon's penis by a bookseller did you
know this it's used as a bookmark
it's a shoelace yeah that explains a lot
yeah when this guy's reading 50 shades
of grey and he gets to a
he's tired and he wants to just turn in
for the night he puts napoleon's penis
uh into the book and shuts it yeah after
he uses it to floss his teeth okay next
question
you know what you can and you just did
yeah you did it's an achievement using a
dick is floss
i think that's where we draw the line
for
big dick history well we had to find it